listen you you play you played Pat
Mahomes twice a year I used to play them
twice a year now I'm just playing them
once a year get a fans you know our idea
how how tough it is to stop Patrick
Mahomes and what it's like to play
against Patrick homes because the guy
for me was Tom Brady I always play Tom
Brady each and every year but now it's
it's you know the Raiders the Chiefs you
going against Pat Mahomes like how is it
going against Pastor my homes twice a
year and what's it like Russia [__]
yeah honestly uh you know when you watch
him you see the arm Talent you see the
crazy you know left-hand throws when
he's falling like you see all that you
see the ability and you know the
athleticism to get away from you know
Defenders but I think the one thing that
people don't talk about enough is just
this competitive nature like that dude
is one of the most competitive people
I've ever played against you know when
I'm out there he's talking talking [__]
right back at me and I'm coming he like
doesn't and most quarterbacks aren't
like that you know they're silent
they're not going to say much like Pat's
one of those guys that he's going to get
right back in your face and be like yo
like let's go then what's up it's crazy
because we I don't know if we we got a
clip of uh I'll pull that up yeah what
was that what had happened like y'all
you had hair but y'all got into a little
what what had happened yeah we were
playing in KC and uh the environment was
crazy it was Monday Night Football and
uh you know we were going back and forth
I got him with a sack on the first drive
and I ended up getting them a second
time and I'm talking like I'm I'm
naturally you know I'm always barking at
everybody now that's just kind of just
part of my nature and uh Pat wasn't
going for it you know he was talking
back and he's like all right what's up
and so they went down and scored and I'm
standing I'm watching them in the end
zone and Pat was running with a guy or I
think his Kelsey scored and they were
all running around the end zone and I
get bumped behind my back I get hit with
his shoulder I'm like and I turned and
it was Pat and he was still running and
I'm like oh no I'm not going for that so
I ran straight to him and I head butted
him like what's up so we were just John
and you know everybody online obviously
made a big deal of it but after every
single time we play he's the first guy
that comes up to me and we always show
love so I got a bunch of respect for him
and you know it's an honor you know I
can chase him down all the time but I
got huge respect for Patrick Mahomes